Okay, my boss assigned me a task and I need to make a proposal for a company in the Netherlands that's called Energy 21
that works with a company in Paraguay that's called D.P.G. Waste Poll Group.
Basically, what they need is for us, AI Whispers, to create an N8N workflow
but actually it's not just one N8N workflow, basically what they want is a ticket analyser
they want to stop wasting so much time fixing stuff
and the whole idea is that they have a place where they get the input from the clients
like if something is failing, if something isn't working
and some of the times it's just answering to the people
but other times there's actual bugs in the program or whatever
so the idea is to have a workflow where an AI can answer and fix and iterate
and fix basically all of the things it can fix already
and only the things that it cannot fix, it goes to an actual person to look over
so instead of having one person manually look over all of the comments and all of the inputs and all of the emails or whatever
you have an AI looking at all of that
and you're wasting less time in that
Now the other thing is the ticketing system itself
to have, based on the things that it couldn't fix
or I mean, yeah, to create the stories and tickets with all the information needed to fix those things
and the idea is to basically because Energy 21 isn't wasting
it's not using their resources or their employees to do these things
to learn these tools and do this automation
basically hire external talent, AI whispers
to set this up for them
and so the idea is to create the workflows and set them up
so they can start implementing that
probably additionally they're gonna need courses or I don't know, explanation on how everything works
but I need to make a proposal for this
like how are we going to make things, how long is it going to take
how much are we expecting
how much do we want to be paid for this job
basically I want a proposal that convinces them
why it's worth paying what we're going to ask
which I have to calculate but the idea is to put us in positive numbers
and yeah
like my boss, my main investor and my co-founder were talking
they have this idea to
it's actually a marketing idea
because we are AI whispers, we are magicians of the AI
basically the idea is we are setting our company to be AI native
and work and be efficient
basically all of the things that we want to offer
to do for other companies that we are already using those things
that we are already implementing that
we are the proof that those things work
and why they should be doing like that
why they should be using AI
to not fall behind other competencies